hello everyone this is a game from round
11 of the grand chest towards the second
leg the tournament in Paris and this
again between vishwanath an island then
Hikaru Nakamura I will show you this
game and also another one because I need
your help to determine what actually
happened in that game I did not follow
the live coverage so it's it's a really
awkward position and I really have no
idea what happened but we'll get to that
before I show you the game we don't have
a nice photo challenge for this video
and I've actually never seen this photo
so you know chances are some of you
haven't seen it either it's a it's a
very interesting but you should
immediately recognize the player but
it's it's a very nice photo so best of
luck to everyone here it is so who is
this person on the left so there you
have it best to walk to everyone now
let's check out this game now like we
said it's a game from round 11 it's the
blade section of the tournament in Paris
and Anand opens the game with E 4 we
have d6 the Pearce defense d4 g6 Knight
to c3 Bishop to g7 knight of three
Knight of 6 so the classical variation
of the pills Bishop to e2 we have
castles castles knights the c6 and the
d5 now the camera goes back with the
knight Knight b8 we have rook to e1 and
c6 now h3 b6 preparing to develop the
bishop via b7 Bishop to f4 and the
bishop to b7 now Queen to d2 creating
the the standard Queen Bishop setup to
go with Bishop to h6 at some point 9b d7
we have a four maybe wood ideas of
preventing b5 and if this night ever
wanted to go to b5 maybe to be able to
kick it with a 5 we have a 6 d captures
on c6 Bishop captures and c6 and Bishop
to d3 now as there was a double attack
towards d4 pawn he five attacking the
bishop bishop go to h6 which was the
plan all along
Knight to c5 and now Bishop captures and
g7 King captures and b4 expanding on the
Queen side but also giving up the light
square Bishop Knight captures pawn
captures and now looked we ate and if
you look at the position it's a pretty
equal
position the pawn structure is almost
almost the same to pawn islands each two
points on the Queen side four five on
the kingside and the development is
pretty much equal so pretty much an
equal position d4 of course and once the
cleared is diagonal if captures captures
then this d4 would be an excellent
square for the Queen and if not his plan
is to close the position with the d5
bishop the b7 d5 now and now rook the c8
we have 1 2 e 3 and now rook comes to C
for now Nakamura's plan as there is no
more alike the light square bishop in
Anna's camp had created a row Queen rook
battery and under on the C file b5 we
have Queen to c7 and rope to c1
defending the c3 Knight other rook comes
the c8 and now you can see what Nakamura
has on the C file very scary
B captors an ASIC special characters on
a6 and now Knight to a to Allen's
position is already very difficult here
he would like to exchange all the pieces
on this C 1 square as both the Queen and
night and this rook are guarding it
but this unfortunately allows the Knight
captures on e4 so this is a clear point
for Nakamura
we have captures on c4 and here Queen
captures on c4 by Nakamura Bishop
captures on c4 would have been better
than after Queen captures simply Bishop
captures and black keeps the extra pawn
it's very nice but here Nakamura played
Queen captures on c4 and he did allow
this Queen captures on b6 move which was
not played but here after Queen captures
rook captures only for the the game goes
on but here after Queen captures on c4
Knight captures a me fight was played on
and sacrifices upon to create a very
strong past D pawn so we have d captors
on e5 Queen captures on in for Queen
captures on a 2 now of course Nakamura
grabs the the piece and the Queen
captures on e5 with Czech king Jade and
now Queen to d4 defending his a four
point but also attacking Nakamura's b6
pawn we have Queen c4 offering a trade
of Queens
now comes Queen captures on b6 of course
you cannot capture
quality for under five because the
bishop will be hanging so queen capture
Sunday for and now d6 so as you can see
I'm Nakamura I still up a piece but the
past born is already on d6 we have
Bishop to b5 not allowing the pawn to go
any further and now Queen to d7
attacking the rook rook to f8 and now
comes rock to c1 so if if for example
the rooks could get exchanged on the
board then this d6 pawn would be very
powerful as the light-square bishop
could never take it and the Queen alone
could never capture it so black would
constantly have to keep an eye on the
point and never allowing it to actually
read your d7 so perhaps there could be
some growing chances here Bishop to d7
now blocking the pawn and now Queen to
d5 we have Queen to f4 attacking the
rook and c1 but also guarding the h2
square so then if the rook leaves the
first rank then ideas maybe rook b8 to
be one could would be deadly here we
have rook to c7 attacking the bishop by
anand and after Bishop to e6 by Nakamura
it was in this position that we wanna
talent resigned in the game now you can
see that there really isn't anything to
do here after we move the Queen likes a
queen d1 then comes rock to b8 as we've
discussed and now you can't push the
pawn this is the problem if you put upon
than Queen captures rook and once you
move the rook maybe free the pawn let's
say Roxy - then comes Bishop f5 alright
doesn't matter where you put the rock
but after Bishop f5 the bishop is
guarding b1 rugby 1 is the threat the
queen is covering h2 there is nothing
for y to do here anymore
so after this Bishop to e6 move which
aren't Anand resigned the game and a
very nice victory in round 11 for Hiro
Nakamura with the black pieces and with
the base defense and before we talk
about something else I would just like
to show you real quickly here this is a
game where Nakamura had the white pieces
I'm not gonna show you the entire game
because it's very short but this is the
position in question so this is a
Nakamura position with the white pieces
he's playing against Vladimir Kramnik
and here of course Nakamura played
Bishop to e5 attacked chronic stroke
here of course if you move the rock then
Nakamura will go here and win the
exchange so chronic played rough to d7
and here Nakamura played Bishop captures
on f6 and I have no idea what happened
here it says Nakamura won the game but I
don't know that chronic resigned it
chronic loose on time because there is
no reason to lose here as black is
better here so if any of you have seen
the live coverage you know do share in
the comments if you know what happened
here because whatever black plays black
can simply capture the bishop and if you
capture the rook now then Queen captures
rook on a one Queen blocks captures
captures and after Bishop attacks rook
rook moves C capture some b3 black will
always be upon up regardless of what you
play and again after Bishop captures
here even if something like rook
captures some d2 is played this is also
fine for black Bishop captures rook
captures Bishop captures keen captures
and after pawn captures Bishop captures
we have Bishop here rook here captures
captures black will again be up upon so
it's a very strange and unfortunately I
didn't catch real-life coverage so I
have no idea what a white chromic lost
after nakamura special characters than
f6 so now i just wanted to ask that if
any of you have seen the live coverage
but yeah in this game after Bishop three
six and resigned the game and here we
have these are the final standings after
the the Paris blitz and rapid section it
was actually Wesley so who won the rapid
section but then but he only was up for
one point and not three points like in
Leuven so here after both rapid and
blitz its Hikaru Nakamura in first
followed by Sergei Karekin then Wesley
so Lebanon maxima Sheila graph then
Anand Alexander II shook mamedyarov then
again Fabiano Caruana in 9th place and
Vladimir Kramnik in 10th and as you can
see Carmona
it was not his day in Leuven and also
not in Paris so he if he definitely if
he wants to do something against Carson
in November he should do it while he's
still in the Classical time format and
this was only after the Paris and these
are the combined results
from Leuven and from Paris so what's
Lisa's still in the lead then he Carnac
more than Kirk and then Maxima Sheila
Grove didn't live on our land then
Alexander Grisham then mountain Anand
Sharma meet our end in last place
Fabiano Caruana so to that those were
two legs of the Grantchester next is the
scene filled cup and those two four four
people who will do the best in the
sinful cup will qualify for the London
so yeah there that's it for this game I
do hope you enjoyed it and here we have
kind of a kind of a special announcement
as today is the first round of the plot
a they are a tournament in Spain it's
basically a tournament of Legends as you
can see here no this is just an this is
Nakamura being given his prize for
winning the tournament in Paris so
there's that but this is also what I
wanted to show you
no it's not there just a second sorry
about that I have it here somewhere
just a second I really thought I had it
prepared very strange yeah here it is
sorry about that
so these are the players that will be
playing in the Plataea dro tournament
that yesterday was the opening ceremony
but today is the first round there will
be a couple of rounds of rapid and then
a couple of rounds of blitz as you can
see here we have your haenyeo tori
anatoly karpov Luba middle boy which and
Anatoly was here so definitely a
tournament of Legends and I will do my
best to cover all of the interesting
games as you know could be could be very
interesting all of them were old rivals
so you know who could be quite a lovely
tournament and I'm gonna tell you a bit
more about this tournament after I cover
the first the first game from this
tournament so yeah once again this
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I think before thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
perhaps with with again from the
tournament of Legends and I will do a
poll today so you can vote on the next
series thank you all and I will see you
soon